12 jornadas de protestas contra la
reforma de las pensiones del gobierno de
Emanuel macron son dos meses en total en
un momento de inflación global sin
embargo para El Vocero de la federación
progresista florian lafard la oposición
continúa pero lo que no se puede
esconder es que a pesar de esta bajada
de movilización que quizás también es
una una un cambio también del mundo de
protestación lo que podemos decir es que
la frustración general es muy fuerte
mucho más fuerte que antes y que la
oposición a este proyecto sigue
manteniendo a un nivel muy alto este
viernes se espera que el consejo
constitucional decida si el texto puede
ser amparado por la Carta Magna para la
faz hay tres escenarios el primero una
anulación parcial de artículos de la
Reforma que podría desembocar en un
referendo el segundo el rechazo total de
la Reforma que significaría la caída del
ejecutivo y el tercero pasar todos los
artículos esto podría llevar al divorcio
otras instituciones con parte de la
población francesa desde el gobierno
esperan poder aprobar la reforma con el
visto bueno del constitucional
no queremos que haya ninguna expresión
violenta ni ninguna presión de ningún
tipo sobre ninguna institución de la
República el consejo constitucional
tiene derecho a la serenidad de los
debates y tiene derecho a que la
decisión que se adopte sea cual sea sea
respetada por todos
entre los objetivos de la Reforma está
aumentar la edad de jubilación de 62 a
64 años el gobierno argumenta que es
necesario para evitar que el sistema
pensional quiebre los sectores
opositores acusan de falta de debate
legislativo